hello I'm Rochelle Carey and this is al
Jazeera bringing you special coverage of
the unrest in the United States over the
death of an unarmed black man in
Minneapolis for a fourth day now there
have been violent protests all across
the country from New York to Los Angeles
so as night falls across the u.s.
curfews are now being enforced and more
than a dozen cities Los Angeles Atlanta
Portland and Denver are among those
restricting movement to try to curb more
violence in Minneapolis though people
are again defying the orders and
continuing to make their voices heard on
the streets the state's governor has
fully mobilized the National Guard for
the first time in Minnesota's history he
says he still does not have enough
troops Tim Walz has also called on
people to do their part to stop the
violence it's couples have broken out
between police and protesters in New
York where demonstrations are continuing
into the night that at least two police
cars have been set on fire and thousands
of people have demonstrated outside the
city Supreme Court on the Brooklyn
Bridge and outside a sports arena these
cars also set on fire in Miami what was
initially a peaceful protest turned
violent officers responded with tear gas
and fireworks a curfew has been in place
there for just over an hour we have
reporters standing by live in four major
cities garrulous Ando is in New York and
the Gallagher is in Miami robber Knowles
is in LA and in Minneapolis where this
all started
John hindrance Oh al-jazeera stron
hendren is there right now so as we
talked about these curfews are in place
what is happening now John and if what I
saw a little bit earlier you were kind
of in the thick of things as police were
starting to sort of move in on people
tell us what you've been experiencing
that's right we were standing in a spot
where there was a very peaceful protest
at hundreds of people going on but that
protest was right in front of a police
station and the police had manned that
area the night before so the protesters
took it back and the police came out in
force
they threw grenades you know smoke
grenades rubber bullets and tear gas
came out immediately and I emphasize
this was a peaceful protest that was
going on at the time the police then
marched in
a number of as we were just preparing to
get on air we were tear gas and and
these are the bullets that they were
firing they're sort of rubber pellets
and I've seen a number of people who
have been hit by them so the police have
taken back an area and one of the
reasons that they may be able to do that
is that the governor called in a
thousand extra National Guard troops
that makes 1,700 in total in addition to
all of the police who are here so the
police have pretty much clamped down
they seem to be enforcing the curfew
tonight but they haven't been able to do
that all week and there has been some
violence and looting of buildings a
number of buildings were set on fire and
we witnessed that last night so John
obviously what said all this well what
set off all this office as decades and
decades of racism and police brutality
but this particular thing obviously was
about what happened to George Floyd one
officer has been arrested Derrick shabam
but one of the reasons that the
protesters escalated this is because it
took days to get that arrest and there
are still other officers that sat there
and watched
perhaps participating that have not been
arrested as the governor or the mayor or
anybody addressed what is going to
happen with these other officers that's
a good question no we don't know and
that's one of the reasons people are out
in the streets want that one officer has
been charged with murder at three have
not and so many of the people I've
talked to said that that is a key goal
of theirs they want to see only four of
those officers charged but right now
there's just a standoff in the streets
nobody nobody's actually saying what's
happening the investigators have said
they're looking into the case but those
three officers have not been charged as
of now and I just want to explain to you
why we're here right now so we have a
crowd of people all standing at this
corner because what you can't see in the
dark there is a line of police officers
anybody who approaches that line gets a
warning and then rubber bullets are
fired so nobody is able to approach this
entire area our car happens to be in
there so that's an inconvenience for the
evening but this is another night if it
were if it continued to be peaceful
throughout the city it would be the
first night
the death of George Florrick okay I'm
Gabriel Elizondo they're at a Ground
Zero but this all started in Minneapolis
thank you very much I'm sorry Jon
Hendren now let's go to Gary Elizondo
who is live in New York so Gabe what is
it that you are seeing there in New York
one word chaos is what we've seen in the
last hour so we're just about a block
south of Union Square very popular a
square in New York City
there has been mass protests and we've
also seen scenes like this some scenes
of smashed windows there protesters
there had been gathering here in Union
Square over the last hours so police
came in dispersed some of them but the
scenes got very very ugly here this was
after a day that we saw thousands of
protesters marching through the streets
of New York mostly peaceful throughout
the whole day but then it got ugly you
can see that a van over there was burned
this was just in the last 45 minutes or
so you can see the remnants of trash
cans off there on the right on the
ground as police are still here just
sort of cleaning up what's left of the
absolute mess here and you can see that
the situation was not very good
some of the protesters smashed NYPD
police vans that you see here what
you're looking at here is a
manifestation of anger we've been
speaking to people all day young people
and they are furious and they're taking
out their anger quite frankly any way
they can
vast majority of the people very much
peaceful it should be pointed out
practicing their First Amendment rights
if you will but of course there were
some situations where it descended very
much into chaos here especially in this
area around Union Square we also saw
protests in Brooklyn as well so Gabe I'm
glad you brought that up that this is a
manifestation of a lot of anger almost
every city where these protests are
happening has their own personal high
profile case of a black man being killed
in police
city and there not being any
consequences for it amadou diallo Eric
Bell Eric garner I can't breathe case
after case after case so while this may
technically seem that it started in
Minneapolis there's a reason that these
things are also happening in New York
when it comes to police violence
New Yorkers know it very well it's a
very raw subject matter here as you
mentioned 2014 Eric Gardner an unarmed
african-american man was tackled by some
NYPD officers and as he was brought to
the ground there's that famous cell
phone video of him saying I can't
breathe I can't breathe that led to
protests here in New York and some
around the US as well and that was 2014
so what we're doing is we're seeing this
again many you New Yorkers especially
young brown black Latino are seeing it
again in Minneapolis and they're finally
saying this is enough enough is enough
I've seen some real anger on the streets
here that I just haven't seen previously
in protests and of course you can see it
here but it's this this is of course
violent anger what you're seeing here
but we should point out there are tens
of thousands of people on the streets
peacefully marching through through New
York as well this is one part of it it's
just one snapshot of it it's real but of
course as you mentioned this city on the
people in this city know these
situations like what happened in
Minneapolis because they've lived it
here before with very high-profile
causes the most recent being Eric
Gardner 2014
and in that case the officers that were
involved were fired but weren't
prosecuted and into that very point when
they when the officers are fired they
often get their jobs back or in the case
of what happened with Eric garner it
took five years for that officer to be
terminated from the force five years
mayor de Blasio was the mayor at the
time Andrew Cuomo was the governor at
the time so while they may say now that
they understand what the protesters feel
that may not resonate with the
protesters it hasn't you asked that
nobody on the streets that we've spoken
to today wants to hear about de Blasio
the mayor or the
govenor quite frankly nobody cares that
I've spoken to they are out here because
they said we've seen this before now
we're seeing a replay of this again
de Blasio the mayor the governor they've
all come outs and we support the
protesters we too want justice for poor
for what happened in Minnesota but the
protesters say we've heard it before
we've heard it over and over and that's
why you see what you're seeing the
people out of these these numbers okay
Gary Elizondo with the latest on what's
happening there in New York and the
protests and the anger okay thank you
very much let's go to Miami now where
Andy Gallagher is live for us there in
the state of Florida as I just mentioned
to gave Andy every state has had their
own personal experience with dealing
with the death of of a black man and
there being no consequences for it
Trayvon Martin obviously this happened
in Florida he was very young he was
killed by George Zimmerman not a police
officer but someone who behaved as if he
was and there were no consequences this
has been building in a lot of states in
a lot of places what is happening in
Miami well about an hour ago I got a
notice on my phone an emergency alert
saying that miami-dade County is now
under curfew like many other cities
across this nation over the past two
hours we saw what started as peaceful
demonstrations become something else
entirely in downtown Miami protesters
surrounded the main police station there
one car was set on fire the i-95 the
main highway that runs up the east coast
of Florida was partially closed for some
time because the protesters moved up on
to that highway walking in between the
cars but as you said there is a very
real history here in the state of
Florida particularly with that case of
Trayvon Martin who was gunned down by
George Zimmerman a self-appointed
neighborhood watch captain that happened
eight years ago it was a case I covered
from the very start and it was a case in
which George Zimmerman was found not
guilty by a jury that still resonates
with the african-american community here
that pain is still very real and
remember just last month the case of our
burry
in Georgia who was basically corralled
Ahmad our briefs arias who was corralled
by two white men who armed themselves
and killed him one of them being a
former police officer himself and of
course then there were a Corey Jones
case here just a couple of years ago he
broke down on the side of the road he
was also shot dead by police officer who
was also found innocent so that pain
particularly reverberates in this state
remember the Trayvon Martin cases what
started what kicked off the black lives
matter movement but what we've seen here
in Florida all across the state are
small protesters small groups of
protesters just a few hundred here and
they're not the numbers were seeing in
New York and certainly not like it is in
Minneapolis but nevertheless that fear
that anger that sense of injustice is
really boiling over here as it is in the
rest of the country the protests now in
downtown Miami seem to have dispersed
I'm hearing reports that protesters
turned up at the house of the police
officer had his knee on the neck of the
manomaya Minneapolis for nine minutes he
apparently had a second home here so the
police are also there as well still no
word from Rhonda Santos this state's
governor a close ally of President Trump
he hasn't made any public comments at
all at the moment but this state
certainly this county now under curfew
we'll have to see what the next few days
and hours bring but things certainly
seem to be under control here in the
state of Florida at the moment okay I'm
Andy Gallagher with the latest they're
in Miami Florida thank you very much and
let's cross to the other side of the
country now the West Coast where our Rob
Reynolds is live in Los Angeles so let's
talk about the history of Los Angeles
Rob obviously if you go back to 1992
there were the LA riots when the
officers who beat Rodney King on video
had minimal if any consequences at all
we're not seeing obviously the level of
the LA riots there but there's a history
of anger and racial injustice in that
city as well that's right Rochelle in
and as you rightly point out it was not
actually the beating of Rodney King
captured on camera and widely
by everyone around the country that
spurred the worst of the rioting it was
a year later when the police officers
who beat King were acquitted by a mostly
white jury in a suburb of Los Angeles
and that's what set the the fuse and and
and led to some of the worst rioting
certainly the worst rioting in this city
and probably some of the worst in the
United States in at least in in in
recent decades right now we have
confirmed that Mayor Eric Garcetti has
asked the governor Gavin Newsom for the
National Guard to be deployed in Los
Angeles the city as of right now is
under a curfew beginning right now and
will extend until around dawn tomorrow
morning there has been extensive
ransacking of stores some high-end
stores in some very posh shopping areas
in Beverly Hills and other parts of West
Side Los Angeles people went in and took
things that they certainly didn't pay
for just in the last 20 minutes to 30
minutes or so we learned of reports of
the los angeles police firing rubber
bullets and beanbag try projectiles as
well as some tear gas at people who were
trying to get into a grocery store so
things are not going well as night falls
in Los Angeles things are getting worse
so let's only ask you about that so Los
Angeles is an extremely spread out city
the Greater Los Angeles area is this
happening in just very concentrated very
specific areas you know this is an area
the worst-hit area is an area called the
Fairfax District this is again an area
where there's a lot of shops affluent
area
not a high minority area like South
Central LA was which was convulsed by
the riots of 1992 but it's a it's a
shopping area a lot of entertainment and
so on also in Beverly Hills where there
was some ransacking and some fires lit
so it has been concentrated in those
areas now on the contrary on Friday
night there was widespread unrest in the
very center of Los Angeles including
protests excuse me protesters blocking a
major highway and there were a lot of
arrests five hundred arrests on the
evening of Friday so you can see these
pictures here people are going into
stores and coming out with their hands
full it is ironic Rachelle that this
weekend was supposed to represent a new
phase of Los Angeles's reopening for
business in the midst of the Cova 19
crisis instead we have this
and actually Robin I'm glad she brought
that up because none of what is
happening is happening in a vacuum it is
happening with the country the world
that is in the midst of one of the worst
pandemics in history thousands of people
are losing their jobs and quite frankly
a US president who grows rhetoric and
send Airy rhetoric empty all of the mix
so when you put all of those things
together any one of those things
themselves would be bad enough when you
put them all together perhaps this is
what you get and I would also add to
that Rochelle that the Cova 19 pandemic
in the United States in the cities New
York Los Angeles elsewhere have hit the
the the black and brown communities much
harder than any other community so that
you have a disproportionate number of
African Americans dying from the the
virus that's all in the background as
well as you say nothing happens in a
vacuum the
enormous disruption that has happened as
a result of the pandemic is certainly a
factor here as is the drumbeat of videos
coming out one after the other showing a
black man in North Carolina being gunned
down by people as he took a jog a woman
in Central Park threatening to call the
police on a black bird watcher and and
and telling the police that he was
threatening her when he wasn't and then
of course the really I don't know what
the word is disgusting perhaps video
from Minneapolis so all of this it adds
up I think it it it you late and that's
at a certain point something breaks and
there's a lot of things breaking right
now
well said Robert Olson it's about a
quarter after 8:00
in the evening there in Los Angeles so
it's actually still fairly early so keep
an eye on things and we'll get back to
you thank you